IOWA.
WE WILL BRING THEM TO YOU AS
THEY BECOME AVAILABLE WHICH
COULD HAPPEN IN A FEW MINUTES.
WHATEVER HAPPENS IN IOWA IN 274
DAYS, YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
YOU WILL RENDER WHAT IS THE
ULTIMATE VERDICT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE
ACQUITTED ON WEDNESDAY AND THE
LATEST IMPEACHMENT WITCH HUNT
WILL BE DEAD.
THE POWER TO DECIDE OUR FUTURE
NOW RESTS SQUARELY IN YOUR HANDS
ULTIMATELY.
THE ULTIMATE JURY.
YOU CAN IN 274 DAYS SHOCK THE
WORLD AGAIN IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE STATE RUN
MEDIA, THE MOB, THEY HAVE
NOTHING TO OFFER EXCEPT WHAT
THEY HAVE GIVEN US FOR THREE
YEARS.
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, LIES,
SMEARS, SLANDER, HOPES AFTER
HOPES.
AN UNHEALTHY OBSESSION WITH
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, UKRAINE,
UKRAINE, IMPEACH, IMPEACH.
THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY IS
SHAPING UP TO GET TO BE YET
ANOTHER DUMPSTER FIRE LIKE IT
WAS IN 2016.
LOOK.
SOCIALIST BERNIE SANDERS HAS
SURGED INTO THE LEAD ON THE
DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT IN A
STATE OF SHOCK AND PANIC.
YOU HAVE THOSE ASSOCIATED WITH
BARACK OBAMA, THE CLINTONS, THE
SO-CALLED MAINSTREAM DEMOCRATS
EVERYWHERE SEEM TO HATE
BERNIE SANDERS.
CHRIS MATTHEWS AND OTHERS ON MY
CONSPIRACY THEORY CHANNEL OPENLY
WORRYING THAT NO DEMOCRAT CAN
BEAT TRUMP.
JOHN KERRY REPORTEDLY OVERHEARD
TELLING SOMEONE THAT
BERNIE SANDERS COULD TAKE DOWN
THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE FIRST SAID EXPLETIVE ON
TWITTER AND THEN HE DELETED THE
EXPLETIVE.
TOM BROKAW THINKS IT WOULD BE
REALLY HARD FOR THE PEOPLE TO
VOTE FOR BERNIE’S BRAND OF
SOCIALISM.
TOM, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT,
LITTLE SECRET HERE.
THEY ARE ALL RADICAL EXTREME
SOCIALIST.
THE NEW GREEN DEAL.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT
MEDICARE FOR ALL AND HAVE IT
THAT OBAMACARE THING WORK OUT?
2016 DEMOCRATS, WELL, THEY DID
THEIR BEST TO RID THE PRIMARY
AGAINST BERNIE SANDERS IN FACT
REMEMBER INTERIM DNC CHAIR
DONNA BRAZILE DISCOVERED
THAT THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND
THE DNC HAD IN FACT BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER TO DEFEAT BERNIE
THROUGHOUT THE PRIMARY.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE SYSTEM WAS
RIGGED.
ACCORDING TO BREAZEALE, SHE HAD
EXERTED THIS CONTROL OF THE PART
LONG BEFORE SHE BECAME ITS
NOMINEE, MEANING
HILLARY CLINTON.
NO HISTORY SEEMS TO BE REPEATING
ITSELF.
THE DNC IS CHANGING THE RULES SO
THAT ONE OF BERNIE’S TOP
CHALLENGERS MAY BE BLOOMBERG OR
WHOEVER ELSE, CAN TAKE THE
DEBATE STAGE WITHOUT MEETING
REQUIREMENTS.
BLOOMBERG MEANWHILE IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE DULLEST HUMAN BEINGS
ALIVE.
BEST KNOWN FOR BEING A 12 YEAR
CARETAKER OF MAYOR GIULIANI’S
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN NEW YORK AND
LECTURING NEW YORKERS ON HOW
MUCH SO THEY CAN DRINK AND HOW
MUCH SALT THEY CAN USE.
THERE IS A STRONG ADVOCATE BY
THE WAY OF GIULIANI’S ACCESSIBLE
TO THEM FIRST POLICY FOR 12
YEARS BUT UNTIL RECENTLY.
HERE WE ARE, SEVEN YEARS AFTER
THAT, NOT BLOOMBERG, YES,
IDENTITY POLITICS DID IN FULL
PLAYWRITING FOR POLITICS HAD
A SUDDEN CHANGE OF HEART AND HE
HAS TO PLAY NICE WITH THE
IDENTITY POLITICS PLATFORM SO
HE’S PRETENDING TO BE DEVASTATED
THAT FOR 12 YEARS AND SEVEN
YEARS AFTER THAT THAT HE EVER
SUPPORTED STOP AND FRISK.
WHILE BLOOMBERG IS AN OBVIOUS
HYPOCRITE, BERNIE’S LONG-HELD
VIEWS ARE DOWNRIGHT SCARY.
THAT’S TRUE.
HERE’S WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAD TO
STAY IN OUR EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: WELL, I
THINK HE’S A COMMUNIST.
I THINK IT’S COMMUNISM WHEN I
THINK OF BERNIE.
I THINK A BERNIE AS AS A SOCIALI
FRB ON THE SOCIALIST.
>> Sean: WEDDING, HONEYMOON,
THE FORMER SOVIET UNION.
DOESN’T REALLY GO TOGETHER.
WANTS TO NATIONALIZE HEALTH CARE
WITH MEDICARE FOR ALL.
HE HAS A PLAN TO NATIONALIZE THE
ENTIRE ENERGY INDUSTRY.
WE JUST BECAME ENERGY
INDEPENDENT FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN 75 YEARS.
THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE WORLD’S
ECONOMY.
HE UNVEILED A $16 TRILLION
CLIMATE CHANGE PLAN.
KEEP IN MIND THE TOTAL BUDGET,
WE ONLY TAKEN ABOUT 4 TRILLION A
YEAR.
THAT’S EVERY PENNY.
WE WILL HAVE NOTHING LEFT OVER
FOR THINGS LIKE OH, DEFENSE.
BY THE WAY, LIKE ANY GOOD
SOCIALIST, BERNIE DOESN’T THINK
ANY OF THESE RULES APPLY TO HIM.
LOOK AT THIS REPORT.
SANDERS NOW LEADS THE 2020 FIELD
OF DEMOCRATIC RADICAL SOCIALIST.
ENVIRONMENTALIST, NEW GREEN
DEAL, IN PRIVATE JETS SPENDING.
LET’S JUST TALK ABOUT ONE OF
BERNIE’S, WELL, HIS SURGE.
IT’S PROBABLY THE ONLY DEMOCRAT
RUNNING WHO ACTUALLY EXCITES
PHASE.
WE KNOW THE QUID PRO QUO JOE HAS
INSPIRED VIRTUALLY NO ONE.
HE GOT 75 PEOPLE IN IOWA
RECENTLY AT AN EVENT.
HE IS STRUGGLING TO RAISE MONEY.
HE’S EVENTS BARELY DRAW A FEW
DOZEN PEOPLE.
HIS BIGGEST CAUSE FOR CONCERN
SURROUNDS A SCANDAL THAT WON’T
GO AWAY.
THE BIGGEST LOSER IN THIS LATEST
HOAX.
IT BOOMERANG BACK ON QUID PRO
QUO JOE N0 EXPERIENCE HUNTER AND
JOEL LEVERAGING OUR MONEY.
A BILLION TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
YOU’RE NOT GETTING IT MUST YOU
FIRE THE PROSECUTOR.
YOU SIX HOURS SO HIS SON CAN
KEEP GETTING 83 GRAND A MONTH.
MOST AMERICANS, FAMILY FOUR,
AVERAGE ABOUT $54,000 A YEAR.
IN CASE YOU DIDN’T KNOW.
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER, NO
EXPERIENCE IN OIL, GAS, ENERGY
OR UKRAINE.
WHY WOULD ANY COMPANY PAY
SOMEBODY LIKE THAT OH, LET’S
SEE, MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS?
IT’S CLEAR HUNTER WASN’T TELLING
EXPERIENCE.
HE WAS SELLING ACCESSIBILITY
LIKE IT’S PAID OFF.
BECAUSE IN 2015, THEN
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN DIDN’T
WITHHOLD THAT BILLION.
GUESS WHAT, SON OF A B, THEY
FIRE THE PROSECUTOR.
HE BRAGGED ABOUT IT.
NOW HE’S NOT BREAKING ANY MORE.
IN FACT HE’S GETTING QUITE ANGRY
AND UNHINGED WHENEVER THE
SUBJECT EVEN COMES UP.
LIKE YOU DID WITH SAVANNAH
GUTHRIE, TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS PROCESS OF IMPEACHMENT
HAS ENSURED THAT EVERYONE KNOWS
ABOUT HUNTER’S DEALINGS WITH
UKRAINE.
>> THAT’S A GOOD THING.
NO ONE’S FOUND ANYTHING WRONG
WITH HIS DEALINGS WITH UKRAINE
EXCEPT THEY SAY IT’S IT’S A BAD
IMAGE.
>> DO YOU THINK IT WAS WRONG FOR
THEM TO TAKE THAT POSITION?
>> NO.
>> KNOWING THAT IT WAS REALLY
BECAUSE THAT COMPANY WANTED
ACCESS TO YOU.
>> THAT’S NOT TRUE.
YOU ARE SAYING THINGS YOU DO NOT
KNOW WHAT YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT.
NO ONE SAID THAT.
HE’S A VERY BRIGHT GUY.
>> I GUESS THE QUESTION I’M KIND
OF ASKING, WAS IT RIGHT?
>> APPEARANCE.
WELL, HE SAID HE REGRETTED
HAVING DONE IT.
>> Sean: HE SAID IT.
YOU’RE NOT GETTING THE BILLION
UNLESS YOU FIRE THAT KIND OF
SAVED MY ZERO EXPERIENCE ON.
HE HAS NO ANSWERS BECAUSE THERE
IS A REASONABLE EXPLANATION.
SELLING ACCESSES WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
USING OUR TAX DOLLARS TO DO IT.
IRONICALLY EVERY HYPOCRITICAL
DEMOCRAT AND EVERY MEDIA MOB
INDIVIDUAL THAT FAILED TO DO
WHAT SAVANNAH GUTHRIE DID.
TAKE A BOW.
GREAT JOB.
THE BIDEN FAMILY BUSINESS, THE
SYNDICATE, WAS TURNING A MASSIVE
PROFIT EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
VOTERS OF EVERY REASON NOT TO
TRUST HIM AND BY THE WAY, HIS
FRONTRUNNER STATUS IS IN
JEOPARDY TONIGHT WITHOUT A DOUBT
HYPOCRITICAL AND CORRUPT
DEMOCRATIC FIELD IN MODERN
HISTORY.
AN EXTREME.
THE PRESIDENT POINTING OUT, THIS
ELECTION IS GOING TO HAVE DIRE
RAMIFICATIONS FOR OUR KIDS AND
OUR GRANDKIDS.
TAKE A LOOK.
IF THEY WERE TO WIN, BASED ON
THEY BEAT THE NEW GREEN DEAL OR
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
WHAT WOULD YOU SEE AMERICA
BECOMING?
>> President Trump: THEY ARE
GOING TO GIVE AWAY THINGS THAT
ARE IMPOSSIBLE.
THEY ARE GOING TO STOP ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
THAT WIPES OUT TAXIS AND MANY
OTHER STATES.
THE GOING TO GET RID OF YOUR
SECOND AMENDMENT.
THE I’VE HEARD CUT TAXES, CUT
TAXES.
THEY WANT TO DOUBLE AND TRIPLE
YOUR TAXES.
THEY WANT TO QUADRUPLE YOUR
TAXES.
THEY WANT TO TAKE EVERYTHING
AWAY FROM YOU.
IF THEY GET IN, IT ALL
COLLAPSES.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN?
PEOPLE’S WEALTH, WHETHER IT’S
BIG WARM MODEST OR WHATEVER IT
IS, YOU’LL END UP IN A RECESSION
DEPRESSION LIKE WE’VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE.
PEOPLE’S WEALTH WILL BE